is a 200 plus page guide from the
district outlining everything from
cleaning standards
to what kids can expect once back orco
mana live in our newsroom taking a
closer look
[Music]
ryan and denise ccsd will begin a hybrid
of distance learning
and in-person instruction on march 1st
but
only for pre-k to third graders now that
means
mass will be born inside the classroom
there will be extra cleaning
and that means a lot of things will look
a lot different
time is ticking for ccsd to get a tiber
learning plan in place
while families have had numerous
questions i believe that majority of
them have been answered
ccsd parent ty bates tells me that's
thanks to this
updated transition guide all students
and staff must wear face coverings with
only a few exceptions deaths will stay
socially distant
and custodians will enhance sanitation
protocols needlepoint bipolar ionization
technology
updated hvac technologies are in the
works to improve indoor air quality too
bates who has a third grade daughter
feels more at ease i'm very confident
in their health and safety measures
they're going to take for the children
as well as their transition timeline but
some teachers say there's confusion over
cohorts
no one really knows what to expect
kindergarten teacher kristen nigro was
under the impression she'd only work
with students doing a mix of in-person
and online learning that's what the plan
says but she just learned she's also
handling
those doing full-time distance education
if we're going to be going back in the
classroom we have to
really you know be able to have a
manageable workload that is the biggest
thing
she hopes to have more clear
communication soon and that's what bates
expects if
coveted cases rise they do see a spike
in the school
or how quickly will we be notified at
that point
now the biden administration wants
schools to reopen
full time saying that vaccinating
teachers does not need to be part of the
equation
the cdc director also adding that we can
safely
reopen schools without doing that
reporting live tonight orcomanna 8 news
now